I met Jennifer a couple of years ago and
she's just been absolutely phenomenal
we've collaborated a bunch of times but
Jay shetty's best collaboration with JLo
officiating her August wedding to Ben
Affleck
you look gorgeous
[Music]
somebody's getting married I can tell
you it was an honor it
I'm gonna let them share more but it was
truly special it was beautiful to
celebrate love and while Jay and Jen
have history the former monk turned life
coach tells us he and Ben are new
friends I got to me been through the
process is wonderful
E.T caught up with Jay at the 2022
Global citizen Festival in New York City
where a who's who of Hollywood turned up
to help end extreme poverty everybody is
a global Citizen and everybody's voice
is important we have the power to be the
change we want to see Jay told ET who he
was most excited to see on stage Charlie
Brooke and Rosalia I think for me they
just the music's incredible my wife's
always playing her in the car and
Charlie Booth I follow his Tick Tock
like crazy so I think he's creative
genius that's awesome
[Music]